- Hi, my name is Everly
and I'm five years old.
Today, two chefs are gonna compete
to make my dream dinosaur food.
(roars like a dinosaur)
- Hi, Everly.
- Hi, I'm Katie.
- Hi, I'm Tway.
- Nice to meet you.
- I am a content creator and a chef here
based in LA and I'm really excited
for my first ever, I Draw, You Cook.
When you see this, what do
you think dinosaurs eat?
- Trees.
- [Tway] Trees.
- [Katie] Oh.
- I've lost this show a few times.
I, I won once.
I'm really glad to be back here.
Just gonna give it another go.
- I do not cook for kids.
I don't really know what they like
besides candy and chocolate.
- [Katie] Is this a big dinosaur?
Is it a baby dinosaur?
- Baby.
- Baby. Okay. That's good to
know about portion control.
- [Tway] Yeah.
I'm feeling shy, I think
Everly's feeling shy.
Luckily Katie's there,
and she's just holding it
together for all of us.
- What are some of your favorite flavors?
- White chocolate.
- [Katie And Tway in
Unison] White chocolate.
- Do you have a favorite food?
- Yeah.
- [Tway] What?
- Cherry.
- [Katie And Tway in Unison] Cherry.
- Just like a cherry, not, just cherry?
Just the fruit?
- [Everly] Yeah.
- [Katie] Yeah. Okay.
- I love how she just responds with, yes.
It's just so easy, because that's me too.
- [Tway] Do you think the
dinosaurs were picky eaters
or do you think they eat everything?
- Eat everything.
- [Tway] They eat everything.
- [Katie] Are you like a dinosaur
or do you eat everything?
- No.
- [Tway] What else do you think they eat?
- Water.
- So is this like regular water
or is it magical water? Is...
- [Everly] Magic.
- [Katie] Oh!
- [Tway] Magical water.
So what does magical water look like?
- [Everly] Colorful.
- [Katie] What are you drawing now?
- [Everly] Rocks.
- [Tway] They eat rocks too?
- [Everly] Yeah.
- [Katie] Are they hard,
or are they, are they like,
you know...
- [Everly] Chewy.
- [Katie] Chewy.
- [Tway] Chewy.
- [Tway] I like that. I like
these rocks. Chewy. Different.
- Different rocks.
- Flavored rocks.
- [Katie] Yes.
- [Tway] Seeing a lot of
colors and I love that.
I just don't know how to incorporate that.
- Does the dinosaur have a name?
- [Everly] Katie.
- [Tway] Katie The Dinosaur.
- [Katie] Wow, my name. I
think that's a great name.
I like that name.
- Everly is so cute.
She's like A, she's adorable
but she's also extremely smart.
- I'm drawing a yummy rainbow.
- [Katie] Oh.
- [Tway] do you know what a rainbow is?
- [Everly] A reflection and
it has all of the colors.
- I barely knew that.
(laughing)
- [Katie] That is gorgeous.
- [Tway] This is a very colorful plate.
- [Katie] So do you think that we can make
this dinosaur food?
- Yeah.
- [Katie] You do? Okay.
- [Everly] Tway, good
luck. Katie, good luck.
- [Katie] Thank you.
- [Tway] Thank you so much.
We need that.
- We're gonna need it.
(roaring like a dinosaur in unison)
- [Katie] We're here, how are you feeling?
- [Tway] I am feeling very confident.
How are you feeling?
- [Katie] Feeling a little
nervous, to be honest.
- [Tway] Okay.
- I think Tway being new to
the show gives her an advantage
cause she can like bring
in this new energy,
this new point of view.
- My game plan is to make a brownie tree.
I'm not really sure what I
want the top of it to be yet.
Maybe some chocolate covered fruits.
- [Katie] So what I'm
thinking about making today
is a Swiss roll tree that's gonna stand up
with these kind of like coral
looking like green things
on the top to be the top of the tree.
So now I'm just gonna separate
the egg whites and the egg yolks.
Oh! I just dropped an egg.
I salvaged it though, so that's good.
She's a picky eater.
It's making me a little nervous
about like how adventurous I can get.
- So I have my brownie mixture here
added two eggs and I'm about
to add some canola oil.
My specialty is definitely
more on the savory side.
So like baking and sweets
is just like out of my comfort zone.
And cooking for kids is
way out of my comfort zone.
- Okay, so now I'm going
to mix these eggs with
half a cup of powdered sugar
until we get some stiff peaks.
- [Tway] So my brownie batter is done.
Now I got some like dinosaurs sprinkles
because this is a magical tree.
- Did you like dinosaurs growing up?
- I'd never really cared about them.
- [Katie] I used to do raptor
impression when I was...
- [Tway] Oh, you have to do it now.
- [Katie] I don't...
- [Tway] No, you have to do it.
- [Katie] You're making me.
- [Tway] I'm pressuring you to, right now.
(raptor impression)
- [Tway] Oh my ga...
- [Katie] I mean, it was
(laughing)
- Wait, she kind of scared me.
- I can't believe I shared
that with all of you.
So embarrassing.
(laughs)
- So my brownie batter is done.
I'm going to be putting this in the oven.
- So I've got my egg yolks.
I'm gonna do a teaspoon of vanilla
and then I'm gonna do the
rest of my powdered sugar.
I got my stiff peaks done.
- [Tway] How stiff is it?
- So, so stiff Tway.
(laughing)
- You have to put it upside down.
- [Katie] Oh, it's not that stiff.
(laughing)
- Now I need to beat my egg yolks,
vanilla and powdered sugar.
- [Tway] I have white chocolate over here.
I'm going to melt down to
make the top of the tree
and add in food coloring
and matcha powder.
- [Katie] Right, so I've got cocoa powder,
all-purpose flour, little bit of salt,
baking powder and baking soda.
And now I'm just going to
sift in my dry ingredients.
- This chocolate is seizing.
I think it's just all in
the heat of the moment
that I forgot to just make a double boiler
for the chocolate.
- The chocolate is
seeming to slow Tway down,
which is what I really need right now
cause I'm very far behind.
So right now I'm gonna
fold in my egg whites,
about a third of them
into my mixture here.
I'm gonna try to make something
that I've seen Rie make
on Make It Fancy.
She made it with Oreos. I'm
not making it with Oreos.
It looks like coral and
it's with flour and water,
but it, it doesn't have much,
I'm gonna do pandan for the color.
Pandan is so good.
- [Tway] That's a good move,
I don't know why I
didn't think about that.
- [Katie] And ube, I am not
using ube, but I love it.
- [Tway] Yeah.
- [Katie] I can see that
this cake is very, very thin.
It's getting me worried about
standing the Swiss roll up.
- I have my chocolate in here.
My water's boiling.
Now we're back.
That really slowed me down.
- [Katie] Let me go bake this.
- [Tway] The chocolate is
melting really beautifully.
Look at that.
So now it's time for me add my matcha.
- [Katie] I'm moving onto
the filling for my sweet roll
which is some whipped cream,
a little bit of sugar.
And then I have a secret ingredient.
It's a little bit of cherry extract
cause she said she likes cherries.
I can smell that it's,
it's a little bit more fake than I'd like.
So I've whipped up my whipping cream
and I'm gonna add a
little marshmallow fluff.
I love a marshmallow filling
and I feel like it'll
make it a little bouncier,
so I'm adding that.
- [Tway] I'm actually using a
skewer to dip my strawberries
because my fingernails were
just not cutting it. Ta da!
Yep. The skew is the way to go.
- [Katie] I'm gonna put
this in the fridge for now
and I'm gonna start prepping for
the Swiss roll to come out of the oven.
- [Tway] And my strawberries are done.
This is a really beautiful treetop.
- [Katie] Okay, here we
go. Here goes nothing.
(slam sound)
(Tway gasps)
Okay. Didn't stick to the pan. Thank God.
It's a little thinner than I anticipated.
- I'm going the extra mile
to make this component
because it is not on the drawing.
I am making a dinosaur pop tart
that's going to live in the dinosaur land.
- Tway is making something
that is not in the drawing
and like props to her. I've
never thought about doing that
and I should, I should've.
- [Tway] This is just
store bought puff pastry.
Nothing special, but
what's going to make it
really special are these dinosaur shapes
that's going to make
the dinosaur pop tart.
So I need two cutouts per dinosaur
so then it can fold on top of each other.
- The cake is sticking to the parchment,
which we don't want.
So I'm losing parts of my cake.
We lost a corner of the cake.
That's all right.
So now this is gonna go
into the fridge to set.
- [Tway] So I have some
strawberry jam here
that I will be putting in between.
It really could go both ways
because she could be like,
I didn't ask for a dinosaur,
or she could be like,
wow, this is really cute.
I appreciate you adding this dinosaur.
So I don't know.
- I am now gonna move onto my treetop.
It's just flour, water and pandan.
It's something I've never done before.
Something I saw Rie do on Make it Fancy.
- [Tway] Oh yeah.
- Yes. And it looks like coral.
- [Tway] Brushing my pop tart
with a little bit of egg wash.
They look so cute.
So I'm gonna use a fork to close off
the edges of the pop tart.
I don't know what it is
about those fork marks
but it just kind of makes
it look more official.
That guy is really cute.
I am only picking one perfect dinosaur.
- [Katie] It's an audition.
- [Tway] For my plate.
Yes, this is an audition.
Whichever one turns out the
best will appear on the plate.
- [Katie] My money is
on the, the long neck.
What's he called? A brontosaurus.
- [Tway] A what?
- [Katie] A brontosaurus?
- [Off Camera Voice] Yeah.
- [Katie] Yes. My money
is on the brontosaurus.
- [Tway] These dinosaurs
are ready to come alive.
- Here I go. Here I go.
I see holes.
I'd like to see a few more holes.
- It's time to make our magical rainbow.
I saw this video on TikTok
where this girl made sour straws
from rice paper and I
thought that was really cool,
and this is the perfect
time to test that out.
I'm making a combination,
like a mixture of sugar
and citric acid right here
where she wets the rice paper
with water and lime juice.
I'm not sure why the lime juice.
Maybe to make it even more sour.
I have a whole bunch of
different color fruits here
and I'm going to roll it up.
I've never done it before
so things could go wrong.
- [Katie] Oh hey. Huh, okay.
(Tway gasps)
- [Katie] Okay.
- Dang, that looks good.
This is the thick sour straw.
- Those sour straws are cool looking.
I should have gone on TikTok.
I'm gonna start cutting up
some fruit while this works.
This is gonna be the rocks.
And then I have a dragon
fruit here that is red.
And I'm just gonna use these
like tiny little cookie cutters
to cut different shapes
into the dragon fruit.
Now I'm gonna cut kiwi for the green rocks
and then I'll do blueberries
and blackberries.
- Are you gonna cut up the blueberries?
- No, can you imagine me like cutting
like even smaller blueberries?
- [Tway] I hope Everly appreciates these
and it's not too weird for her.
I love sour stuff
but I don't know if
Everly likes this sour.
- [Katie] So I'm gonna be
making a rainbow waffle,
Again, another thing
I haven't made before.
So I'm just using like a
regular waffle box mix.
I'm not going fancy here.
Are you very competitive?
I feel that you are.
- As an Aries. Yes, I am very competitive.
- I'm a Pisces, so we're very sensitive
- [Tway] Oh wow.
- [Katie] And cry and
(women laugh)
Very creative.
So I'm just gonna take my
waffle batter and divide it up
between six bowls to get some
different colors of the rainbow.
- [Tway] My rainbow's done and
when I saw Everly draw the rocks
my first thought was chocolate rocks.
It looks like rocks.
And they are also colorful,
like her magical rocks.
- [Katie] Well I have
moved all my batter to bags
and I've got my waffle
maker heating up here.
Basically I'm just
doing circles of colors.
This waffle is a mess right now.
We're just gonna see when I
open it up if it's, it's okay.
We'll see what happens.
(laughing)
- With the rocks,
I'm going to crush up some
cookies to make like dirt.
So it's like realistic.
(gasps)
That looks so real.
- Alright, moment of truth.
(high pitched) Oh, that
one looks so much better...
- [Tway] That looks so good.
- [Katie] Than I thought it
was going to. I'm so relieved.
(claps)
Yay.
I'm gonna unroll my Swiss roll,
and then I'm gonna add some filling.
I'm feeling good, I mean
it's like little soggy,
but it's I'm, I'm okay.
(laughs nervously)
- That tree is not gonna stand. Katie.
(laughing)
- I am now moving on to the magical river.
So I'm gonna take some
yogurt and flavor it
with different like dragon fruit and acai.
Ah, si, ah, si...
- [Tway] A-sa-ee?
- [Katie] A-sa-ee.
(laughs)
- [Katie] Anyway, so I'm
gonna flavor my yogurt
with different colors
and then I'm gonna put pop rocks on it.
When I assemble.
- [Tway] Oo, pop rocks.
Kids love pop rocks.
- [Katie] Do they? What
if she's like afraid?
- [Tway] Oh, that's true.
- [Katie] I do worry like how mature
Everly's like taste buds are.
But if she likes your sour rainbow
she'll probably like some tart yogurt.
- [Tway] Hopefully.
- I'm making this river
and I'm tasting the yogurt
and I love greek yogurt.
But I'm starting to think like as a kid
did I like greek yogurt?
No.
I think I'm gonna add a little
honey to sweeten this up.
Just a tiny bit.
Added some like dehydrated strawberries
to get this kind of red.
And I'm almost done.
- I am going to be making
shaved ice over here.
I will be flavoring it
with different flavors
and colors of syrup.
So this is vanilla syrup
with strawberry extract.
Magical. And then this is grape syrup.
Grape. This grape syrup is kind of dark.
Oh, I love the red.
Now why couldn't the grape be like that?
Then we have blue raspberry
- [Katie] Beautiful river.
- [Tway] I have to go run
and put this in the freezer
and then cut my tree.
- [Katie] My magical
river components are done
and I think we're getting really close.
- [Tway] Let's go.
- [Katie] Let's do it.
- This could be a win if I pull this off,
but if it just all melts together,
sorry, Everly.
So all of my components are here.
My magical pond is in
the freezer right now.
And then I also have my little dinosaurs.
- Who won the audition?
- [Tway] It's between these two.
I think this guy is going
to fit on my plate better
because this is kind of big.
He's, he's a bigger boy.
- [Katie] I was rooting for
the brontosaurus, so yes!
You won American Idol.
(Tway laughs)
American Dino. Okay, I'm sorry.
This is kinda the moment of truth.
Like if things are gonna
stand, are they gonna fall?
So what I'm hoping to do is
use some melted chocolate
as a glue to help that
tree really stay in place.
What am I trying to do here?
(laughs)
It's just breaking under the
weight of the expectations
that I put up on it.
It's not exactly how I pictured it
but you know, sometimes
you just have to accept
what you have.
- [Tway] My tree's going
to have a little bend in it
because this is a round plate.
- [Katie] We're gonna
try to decorate it now
with some frosting,
some chocolate frosting.
- And then I'm just scooping
some chocolate rocks
and the dirt.
I really love the look
of my dirt and my rocks
because it looks real.
What if she doesn't even want to eat it
because it looks too real.
You know this tree top just
looked better in my head
than on the plate right now.
I'm trying to find the perfect
placement for this dinosaur.
I think that might be it.
- [Katie] Looks great.
I'm struggling Tway.
- So we're plating and
I'm looking over at Katie
and her tree is just falling apart.
- It's like, it just looks like, poo.
(laughing)
So I'm gonna just lay it flat.
We're gonna go 2D.
I'm pretty sad that
the tree is what it is.
(off camera laughing)
Thank God I have more tree left.
- It's actually still very 3D.
- Thank you. Thanks Tway.
Tway is so positive.
I'm behind at this point and
Tway is just staring at me
and I'm feeling so much
pressure right now.
We've got the magical river.
Okay, these are blue pop rocks.
I've got rocks and we've got the rainbow
coming out of the tree.
- [Tway] And now for my
magical river. Ta da!
- [Katie] Oh my God,
yours looks really good.
- [Tway] Yours look
exactly like the picture.
So I'm kind of afraid.
- It's gonna be fun.
It's gonna be good. Woo.
- [Tway] Let's go.
(classical music)
- I really like how my dish turned out.
So I think Everly's
really gonna like the tree
cause she said she loves chocolate.
Fruit rocks, a yogurt
river with pop rocks.
I really love how the rainbow
waffle turned out though.
I'm feeling very confident about that.
It's not exactly what I
envision in my head, but overall
I think it came together and
it looks a lot like the photo.
- I'm done with my dish
and by looking at my dish
it has all the components
that is in the drawing.
A brownie tree,
some chocolate covered
fruits, crumbled up cookies,
shaved ice for the magical
river, and then DIY fruit straws.
Visually, I'm not that pleased with it.
I really love my dinosaur though.
That guy is cute.
- Bring in my favorite dinosaur food.
(cymbal and drum sounds)
(classical music)
This looks here really yummy.
That looks like the tree for my drawing.
These look like the rocks I drew.
The river looks very magical.
I wanna try the tree first.
- Fingers cross.
- This taste is really yummy.
Great.
I wanna and tried the rainbow now.
Yummy.
It tastes like strawberry.
- She's only taking like
one bite of everything.
- Good.
- She's giving me vague responses.
- So I couldn't really read
if she really liked
something or if she didn't.
- [Off Camera Voice] Everly, do you know
what your favorite part is?
- The magical river is my favorite part.
- I'm a little worried.
- It looks delish.
- [Off Camera Voice] Can you
tell me what you recognize?
- The tree, the rainbow,
the river and the rocks.
- You can see the drawing on my plate.
My plate is the drawing.
This is good.
- It tastes great.
I like the chocolate tree.
- Seems like she likes it.
- It tasted sour.
- [Off Camera Voice]
Do you like sour food?
- Not really.
- Oh, it's sour. She doesn't like sour.
- [Everly] The river. It tasted sour.
- The river is sour. I
knew it was gonna be sour.
I knew it was gonna be tart.
It is not magical. It is sour.
This is bad. This is very bad.
- Fruit.
- Sweet.
- [Off Camera Voice] Is it good?
- Yeah.
- She was saying she liked the fruit
and then she pushed it off her fork.
- My favorite part of
this dish is the waffle.
- Right now I think it anyone's game.
- Let's bring in the chefs.
(intense background music)
- [Katie] You have fun
eating all that food.
- Yeah.
- [Tway] So which one was your favorite?
The first one or the second one?
- First.
(Tway gasps)
- [Katie] Yay. It was Tway.
- [Everly] Tway. Here's your prize.
- Thank you so much.
I'm definitely going to hang
this up in my new place.
- [Katie] I'm happy for Tway.
I'm crying deep inside for myself.
- First ever win on, I Draw, You Cook.
So bring on the competition.
(roaring all together)
(outro music)